so i said we what we have to do is is
make them look as similar as we can
um which should be possible because i am
the same person um
and and so i muttered up all the clothes
and tried to make makeup the same and
that sort of thing
and found an internal way to make them
different so that they felt very
different well for david cronenberg's
terrific dead ringers in 1988 you're
paired famously with yourself um playing
twin gynecologists each with very
distinct personalities did you learn
something about your your craft or your
technique from in a way acting with
yourself did you learn anything about
your own style
um not really i i learned a little bit
about tricks and and and how all the
good tricks are very simple i think any
magician would tell you that
um
at base they're simple but they dazzle
you when you don't know how they're done
and and i remember coming to
to start work on on uh dead ringers and
we went out the week before on separate
days to buy separate clothes for the
separate characters and they built me
two dressing rooms
and
i i think i shared makeup artists i
think i had the same egg i was doing me
both but
and then we shot for a couple of days
and then we watched the rushes at the
end of the second day and i looked and i
i said to david this is a disaster
they're completely different
i mean no one would ever come ever
muddle them
and that was a important part of the
story that the audience actually was at
times not sure which was which which
was so with the mantle brothers who was
based on the new york gynecologist and
i've spoken to people who went to them
who were there you know went to them
and they said we were never quite sure
who we were seeing
um so we knew we were true to life but i
thought this is as i say a disaster so i
said we what we have to do is is make
them look as similar as we can
um which should be possible because i am
the same person um
and and so i muddled up all the clothes
and tried to make makeup the same and
that sort of thing
and found an internal way to make them
different so that they felt very
different and
it was an internal energy spot very very
simple trick those those of you who are
yes who act i mean one i put the the the
i mean i shouldn't tell you this because
magicians don't um
but but uh one of them i put my um
my energy point here
for for for for elliot
um the smooth one the operator the uh
the guy because this is where you
headbutt people you're very very
powerful here
um
and
the other i put his energy point here
which is where you
can be killed and gets and it's very
delicate and
more feminine
and when you put your energy there
everything changes something changes in
your eyes changes in your posture it
changes how you speak so i was able just
to switch from one to the other between
takes because we would go we would
record one side and then i'd go and
change and we'd record the other side
um
and i didn't have to do any um
you know any more preparation than that
it was just literally flicking a switch
and then of course when you play one of
the brothers pretending to be the other
brother
then you keep the energy the same you
don't move that
but you try and pretend to be the other
brother but the audience can tell
because they see where you're at they
feel you're different i mean it sort of
works anyway simple trick um
so that taught me that but it didn't
tell me about anything about my
technique i know nothing about my
technique
uh i i start every film and play feeling
like a plumber
um that i'm completely out of my depth
and
um and i want to go home
i don't know too many plumbers who could
turn in so many amazing performances i'm
so glad you gave that little back uh
backstage magician's trick of that's a
fantastic little little bit of
information that energy going from there
to their 1990s reversal of fortune of
course uh ended that decade on such a
terrific high note that did win you the
academy award for best actor i know the
voice of after though
the i know the voice closer on vuelo's
voice was uh was a trick for you to get
that what were some of the other parts
of klaus von bulow that that helped you
unlock that role
class was a tough one because when i was
originally asked i thought it was a bit
sort of national enquirer i thought that
you know they're all alive still i mean
sunny hardly but but the the children uh
and klaus and i thought why do we want
to you know they've been through a
difficult time i do want to pull all
this
on the screen
and so i just thought it was rather bad
taste and turned it down
and glenn who wanted to play sunny um
persuaded me eventually you know to do
it and i think she was probably right
um
but i found it very difficult to get
into class because a
he's quite he's bigger than me
he doesn't you know he's a big dane
and um i didn't really feel like him and
i thought i don't know i don't i can't
get inside this i can't get inside i
watched him i watched my barbara walters
and and uh various other interviewers
he'd done because he was quite a he was
quite the thing wasn't he during the
trial i mean people love an enigma they
love they love to ask to dinner somebody
who maybe has murdered his wife it's
exciting you know
and so klaus who who
is a great weekend guest a great uh
high liver um
loves to be the center of uh
of everything um enjoyed all of that and
and and and blossomed and i thought oh
okay honest i still don't like that
quality very much
uh i i talked to john richardson who was
a great friend of his the the uh the
novelist and art critic
um who said to me play him like a bad
actor and i said thanks a lot
so how do i do that i don't know
and
eventually i thought to myself well wait
a minute what's he done he's been
accused of trying to in to kill his wife
by injecting her with insulin now
whether that's true or not i don't know
but
it's he's got himself into
deep water and he's having to go through
this televised trial
and uh
uh i took sort of months
and i suddenly thought what would my
father let's just say
that he had
made some huge mistake or tripped up in
his life and
got into this situation
how would he deal with it
and i thought what he'd deal with it
with charm and and
we'd sort of just get through it
um
and i thought well i'm very like my
father
so if i just play it like that and i
sort of got into him that way
and of course had to make up my mind
whether or not i had tried to kill my
wife by injecting her with insulin
and looked at klaus and thought would he
or wouldn't he
[Music]
looked at the reality of the situation
looked at how happy sunny was with him
looked at how
cross sunny was when she when he brought
her back from her first suicide attempt
and came to conclusions
and then played him
and
never met until about three years after
and
he sent like a series of postcards or
something to you right didn't he send
something well he used to send me
because you see i had to do
trouble with this acting business is you
have to sell the stuff
so i do interviews and you know you're
doing interview about a character you've
played you you you sort of know that
character you are that character and you
talk about him with great authority
but that character existed
so i get these postcards closely written
postcards from class saying i do not
think that i am not like that i do not
believe that
and um
finally well finally i did meet him
at paul gettys who was a great friend of
his and supporter and uh i went down to
a cricket match and paul is a neighbor
of mine uh in or was dedna uh in
oxfordshire in england and i used to
have sunday summer sunday cricket
matches
and my son who was at that age about 11
wanted to get a footballer's
autograph and the footballer was playing
cricket that day so i said well let me
go down and we'll have a cup of tea in
the interval because they used to break
for a nice tea you know paul was not
short of a few bob
and um i said i'll get the interview
i'll get the uh autograph for you so i
go down and paul greets me in the
pavilion and says look
klaus von bulow is in the house if he's
looking at the library and i know you've
never wanted to meet him but so i i
won't mind if you scatter off and i felt
was three years after i made the movie
so i thought no no this would be great
to meet him no he was fine
so we stayed to get the autograph and i
was looking out
the they hadn't broken for tea yet i was
looking out of the pavilion at the match
and i heard this voice behind me there's
a back door to the pavilion and the
voice voice said um you'll see i'm not
fat
and i said no no no no i i turned around
i said i never said you were fat i said
you were bigger than me which you are
you're a bigger man than me i'm quite
slight in comparison
and um he said oh and and we went and
sat down on a bench overlooking the
cricket and um
[Music]
he said uh uh have you ever have you
i've seen alan dershowitz lately alan
daschwitz was the lawyer who got him off
i said no i haven't seen alan played by
ron silva sadly the late ron silva
played him in the movie i said i haven't
seen alan since we opened the movie
three years ago whatever um he said oh
he said i understand he's representing
leona helmsley and michael tyson at the
moment i said yes i i'd read that in the
papers yes he said you haven't been
asked to play either of them
and i i said i felt michael tyson was
slightly beyond my range but i'd have a
crack at leona
[Music]
[Music]
you